[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we have an awesome episode coming at you
we're gonna be talking about data
visualization we're gonna be talking
about complex systems and simplifying
them and we have a very special guest we
have Matthew Rostov ak hello that's yeah
nice Evan thank you for thank you for
coming on to our show
really appreciate it matt has a great
background Matt's background is as a
software engineer he's in his last year
he's going into his last year right now
at the University of Illinois at
champaign-urbana a you know at
urbana-champaign
got it you I you see he is also a
co-president at founders which is an
entrepreneurship Club in Illinois the
Entrepreneurship Club in Illinois and
then he also interned at NASA and
interned at Facebook NASA last year
Facebook this year over the summer and
he's been working on visualizing complex
systems and we got some really cool
visuals to show you and to talk through
today and let's go ahead and jump in
because I love young people and I love
it when we get to talk to young smart
people so people where you say that oh
yeah yeah well hopefully we can get past
that taboo yeah exactly
okay so let's talk let's talk about this
because I think data science and data
visualizations only getting more and
more important because we've talked
about this on the show so much but the
the the the second greatest invention of
mankind is all the data we leave behind
but the first greatest invention is how
do we analyze it and make it applicable
to our lives and we have no idea how to
do that and so you're starting to figure
out how to do that exactly yeah
so as we've been getting so much more
data in various different formats in
various different ways it's been getting
more complex the world has become much
more
flex and just full of this data we don't
know how to analyze it and so we've had
different approaches machine learning
has done a great job of sifting through
giant data warehouses for various
companies for good social uses for
commercial purposes but we still don't
understand a lot of it particularly in
the social realm I mean Facebook exists
and I spent the whole summer there and I
the more I spent time there I realized
we just don't have the tools ready for
doing meaningful analysis on social
networks I mean we still struggle with
the question of how do we make people
happy how do we get more people to
connect with each other find more
friends for them how do we manage their
relationships keep them in contact with
each other and so I think that there's a
very large skills gap in terms of the
people who can do the stuff and the
people who are doing this stuff and
building the applications complex
systems has been traditionally a very
theoretical field where researchers look
at small scale analyses of the economy
of social networks of just various
different social institution analyses
and they make conclusions that
eventually if you dig down deep into it
it goes I don't know there's lots of
assumptions turn around and I feel like
there's definitely a space for making
real applications that can affect
millions of lives and make people
overall more happy by connecting
together and this is a little cybernetic
see right well I guess it depends on the
specific definition of cybernetics how
systems function and work yeah I mean
it's exactly so when you're analyzing
the way that social network works I
think a lot of people have
misconceptions about what does the world
look like from a top level of who has
the money who has the resources down to
the the average citizen and these
misconceptions get in the way of proper
analysis if you assume that everyone has
a network at least similar to yours I
think that you're gonna be a little
disillusioned with with the way that
society actually works yes you you're
giving us these really good examples
kind of on these these different scales
you have like okay here's who Matt is
and here's Matt's like family and
friends and his coworkers and here's his
like Dunbar number of 150 people that he
can closely make connections to and know
off the top of his head etc and then
there's this crazy other side of this
continuum of thought which is the
economy how does an economy work how
does money actually move through the
economy through these trusted
relationships through earning money
spending money all this all this crazy
stuff so then there's this massive scale
the small scale everything in between
and we let's I think we should yet talk
a little bit about like the philosophy
around it because I think a lot of the
political polarization is driving us
towards the sort of binary thinking like
the economy is either yes or no it's
either black or white your networks
either black or white but it's so
nuanced there's so much gray area
there's so much to actually impact there
and it really it kind of it starts with
oneself just being able to say things
like I don't know it starts with I don't
know it starts with admitting that if I
have a thought like for example on let's
say an issue like immigration I should
know everything that's all the way Pro
immigration all the arguments that are
all the way against immigration all the
arguments in-between for all the
different variables and that shows you
how that that that shows you how
educated you are on that topic if you
know all of those different arguments
now the same can be said about economy
or about people networked so talk to us
about your philosophy about complex
systems and the nuance the gray area
sure so
to me I think that there's very few if
any things in life that are black or
white everything to me seems to be very
gray and hence we're almost all grade
almost every day it's just where you're
yeah I don't know what that means but
it's a moon a moon of Jupiter ooh okay
well I know Europa I don't know like
what that indicates about yeah yeah so
that indicates about me maybe that means
that I'm a little bit more eccentric
like unusual I think that makes sense
yeah so you know everything is a
spectrum and one of the things that
plagues policy public policy
particularly is when they try to kind of
pitch and hole all these very complex
issues into let's make a law that does
this and that's why immigration abortion
gun rights all these very hard questions
are so difficult to solve because people
want it one way or the other and that
polarization is partially in fact that
are partially due to the fact that
there's so many different possibilities
that could work under different
circumstances and that's kind of the
point of complex systems if you have
some kind of effect so like you know the
number of mass shootings is an effect of
the system then there could be multiple
causes and if you change the structure
of the system then that could
potentially change the different causes
and how they operate so for example if
you take the gun rights policy issue
into the Netherlands then it becomes a
much different problem because there's a
completely different culture there yes
there's different laws in place already
there people have different ideas and
philosophies and so our arguments
completely don't translate and so that's
kind of the point of complex systems and
why I'm so interested in them it's it's
mostly out of frustration about how
the world tends to be simplified down by
our feeble brains into these yes or no
or ABCDE solutions and I think that
that's not the way it should be and but
unfortunately I think that anything
beyond those types of solutions are
beyond the ability of most people to to
fully grasp and comprehend and we don't
have all the the mental energy in the
world so it makes sense that over time
evolution has told us if you can make a
split-second decision for yes or no Hey
I mean that I'm probably working your
favorite cognition sees human saves you
energy yeah you can get the food you
know it's the food that's really what it
comes down to
so you mentioned something that I think
was so crucial which is effect and
causes on that effect and I think that
if we start looking at the world in that
way I think it'll really make us much
more aware being so for example you took
the amount of people that were that were
died due to mass shootings and that you
took that that that's an effect so
whatever that number is in the last year
is an effect now to say that it's caused
by one variable is ridiculous yeah and
it's even ridiculous to say it's caused
by a dozen variables so now now you're
basically trying to look at a piece of
data which is this effect and then
you're looking at these causes and the
weight of that cause on the variable
which is the effect so all these are
different variables with different
weights that are impacting this and then
if you take it from the US and you move
it to China or the Netherlands it's
completely different
yeah so these systems are and this is
one issue this is the amount of mass
shootings
in the per year right so that's that's
again that's different than the amount
of guns that are sold which is a
different variable itself this is
different than the amount of people that
are in mental institutions that's a
different one as well there's and then
that's different than all the other
complex issues like immigration and like
you were describing all the other ones
so this is why it's so fascinating to me
as well as your frustration with the
polarization with the binary thinking
with the ABCD that's it these four
choices that's it that I have that same
frustration and I'm trying to push
people to have more nuanced
conversations more thought-provoking
conversations and I think that's one of
the reasons why you and I definitely
yeah and I think that it's it's tricky
because there's no solid solutions you
can gain by this perspective shift
really the I can't tell you how to solve
the the mass shootings issue or how to
solve you know abortion rights in an
equitable way all I can say is it's
really complex right and I think that
that's valuable in its own way it allows
you to take it to have a different lens
in the world but at the same time it's
frustrating in a different way of I
understand now that you can't just
bucket this issue into two different
ways of solving it and just pick one
call it a day but I also can't solve it
by knowing that it's too complex to
solve in those ways so that's that's
another issue I think that still plays
me today and like let's go through some
of the the visualizations that you know
that you've made I think these are
really solid and these are these are
good different examples they range
across a variety of issues that you've
built you know your website is pretty
simple it's Matt Roscoe dot me and we
have that link in the bio em attr AST o
dot me and you can go and check it out
check out his projects workshops blog so
as we go to projects we see that you
know you have your project toolbox and
it's sorted by different projects
worked on and we're gonna pull up a
couple of them and show them to you
individually here so let's pull up
exchange first so so I guess I can go
into it so I guess exchange was my first
intro to programming and you can
probably tell that by the wonderful look
of my Bitcoin exchange and that's how I
got into programming in the first place
back in oh gosh I had to have been 2011
or so back before I used github and so I
built a bacon exchange because I liked
the idea of look at this new way of
sending money and it was really the
first challenge to my traditional views
of the finance system is how it is and
it's not going to change and the Bitcoin
came along and all of a sudden I could
think about wow
you can program people's behaviors and
not in so much of a dangerous sense but
you can align incentives so that people
will naturally want to spend more
Bitcoin or don't want to mine instead
save up in different ways and I think
that that was really my first foray into
complex systems in a way and nowadays
there's some somewhat established field
mechanism design and token economies and
those are evolving pretty rapidly
how are you tweaking the variables
because here you know so yeah how are
you tweaking them to get people to
potentially mine more or spend more at a
given time etc so that wouldn't be on
the exchange the exchange was just
something that I could do to learn more
about the space but in general for token
economies let's say you make it so that
I mean let's compare Bitcoin versus
white coin you know you have much
smaller
block size on litecoin that allows you
to do transactions faster the fees are
typically lower but it's that means it's
not well-suited for putting a lot of
data in those those blocks and so you
get the trade-offs and incentive
mechanism design is all about the
trade-offs you know what is best for our
target audience and how do we how do we
program in those the right incentives so
that they're happy and that's why we
have so many different token economies
now we have Bitcoin litecoin ethereum
dogecoin woods being for a while
probably still is I want to weave oh so
much stuff to cover especially what your
recent your most recent AI concept map
that we want to show so maybe let's
speed round through these what we go for
should we keep going then you know I
think that yeah it was a challenge to my
philosophy and that's about all there
was good a simple HTML parser for
biochemical research results to a
genomics researchers geo data yeah so
that was my first internship at a
pharmaceutical company and this really
spoke to me it was my first real
programming job and they asked me to
send a cubicle and look at a website and
copy and paste data into Excel all day
and I was like no so I wrote a program
to do that and I that was just something
that they had well in fun from like 60
minutes to 30 seconds you could do it in
and the 60 minutes 30 seconds it's
fantastic way to save time yeah damn I
think that's important for any it's
subtler hacker just learn how to
automate and have an obsession to yeah
have have an obsession with saving time
with automation with code all day yeah
good [ __ ] good work hell yeah okay so
then let's go to
AB changer so I think it was AB cruncher
sorry yeah I that AB cruncher a
visualization platform for analyzing
interest relations between drug
researchers right and so this was my
first formal intro to data visualization
and complex systems and it was in a
social space so at ab the-- but that's
where the name came from it was a data
cruncher for ab fee so it was named ab
cruncher yes yes
interesting choice I don't know if that
was intentional so they we it's a very
large company lots of PhD bio and chem
people working on experiments and
sometimes they would work on the same
experiment in different buildings
facilities and they wouldn't even know
about it
so that would waste six months and PhDs
are expensive so they wanted to stop
that so we want to just create an
interest graph of all the researchers at
the company based on the data put they
put their internal profile what their
focus was in whatever and that way we
could take a look at an interface like
this to see like what is the who would
you possibly be connected with and maybe
that would inspire collaboration and
hopefully it did I think there were a
few cases of researchers who said oh hey
I should probably talk to this person
and so they could maybe optimize each
other's processes by engaging with one
another
exactly just connecting people in a
meaningful way I think in a work context
in a work context great yeah it's huge -
okay cool and then here's another good
easing up and you got a look yeah you
can watch the video on my website I
think I was sick while recording it and
this is good like you have examples here
of like very connected more connected
less connected barely connected you know
and that's that's a good way to get
people to be like oh wow there's
possibly a really good collaboration
potential here so right so there's
different ways to
to do the layout the other you want to
see the people connected to you or like
see a specific interest in everyone
who's connected and I think that that
was a really valuable experience and
then let's go to Verano yeah a web
application for financial data analysis
so I kind of went into complex systems
and then I realized that there's a lot
of research to do so I kind of got
intimidated and I moved into data
science slash machine learning and so
very specifically I was doing a time
forecast or time series forecasting
which is predicting ahead of time on a
time series like like a stock chart data
over time and so project Verano was a
project I did with a friend from high
school in over to three summers ago and
all was was you look at the S&P 500 and
you plot it over time and we did you
could detect volatility in it and you
could detect I think writers and runs so
very basic but I want to get more
experience with d3 the main
visualization library I use you know and
tell us a little bit about that
visualization library d3 sure so if you
want to do a visualization on the web
with any kind of data a great starting
point is d3 it's a way to add nice
pretty graphs to your websites with
fairly little code depending on how
complex you want to make it and it's
almost a de facto framework for anyone
to use in visualization and so it's very
popular in that field and it works very
well because it's on the web and that
means that everyone with the browser can
use it see it and interact with it and
that's one of its core things that's
interactive so we'll see that in the
concept map yeah exactly so I'm I'm
really excited about
also introducing more people to d3
because I think it'd be really good to
have more people be aware of data
visualization tools and integrating that
into their flows cool so then you were
able to learn about the volatility here
of the S&P as well as the bulls and
bears markets right that's this yeah
that's good so there's tons of different
things that you learned here you know we
were learning about how to best connect
people so much other work which is it's
great to get you kind of flowing with
these projects right I keep telling
people that it's crucial to get them a
portfolio right that yeah that this
generally it was a number one thing I
recommend to any programmer there was
focus on like I do research that I like
try to do a summer job more aligned with
my area and it I mean it's kind of a
chicken and egg problem you can't get a
job without experience and experience
out a job but a portfolio as a way to
just like throw a wrench in that whole
problem that whole system just say I've
done side projects like this and I know
how to program in these languages and
you can see it on my github or on my
website yeah and that's a great way to
signal to employer say you're actually
worth the the risk of onboarding and I
mean that's their number one concern
like are they going to be a productive
employee and if you can show them I'm
productive yep and the just the general
idea of having a place where you can
showcase what you've built
exactly it's and that's my favorite
thing to recommend specifically is make
one personal project and then you make a
website yeah you can display that
personal project on your website it's
perfect flow make Arda got to project or
two and then make a website and then
host those two on that personal website
sack and you're good to go and then just
keep adding what you make to your
website so that way you have a log of
who you are what you've made etc and
show get to being able to showcase that
to people yeah all right so let's go
ahead and start talking about the AI
concept map so
so maybe we should start you know before
maybe even before we get to this dynamic
one let's show the static one sure sure
all right let's show that static the
static image that we have Ron so I think
it'd be the other one then well yeah
this one's a static one but but what is
this one then so this is with phase oh
this is the this is the jiff yeah okay
should we show the static image as well
there's a static one too right it's
right below it I think that's right but
is it right it's okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah there it is yeah the static one yep
yeah go yeah yeah yeah okay so now yeah
what's what's going on here okay so this
one so this one is which is related to
this right not oh it's not we could also
just go off of it
okay well that's what's this one then
this one's with face
oh so this one's oh that's next yes okay
this is next okay sorry
so then you were right put up to the
jiff again yes because this is the net
this is what will where we'll go next
yeah in this in this release of the AI
concept map that we have pulled up right
now so we're about to play that jiff
all right oh this this jiff is also with
face it is also a face yeah okay so then
we'll come to this after we go to a
icons event okay okay cool so then all
right so Ron we're going back to the NDI
connection for now and then we'll go to
this so we have your AI concept map so
tell us a little bit about this because
you were teaching me about the of these
are relationships between machine
learning concepts yes so it's this idea
that if you you know if you come in and
you zoom and you can see oh there's
there's unsupervised learning
reinforcement learning all these
different sorts of machine learning and
how they're related mm-hmm yeah so one
of my problems when I was starting to
really dig into the machine learning
space was how like what is an RNN versus
a CNN versus just a normal and and Arn
and CNN explain what those so RNN
recurrent neural network CNN
convolutional neural network I was like
are those different than a normal neural
network mm-hm
or like are they subclasses of it and
are they different
that so RNN and cnn's are both like
subcategories of neural networks and
they do do different things yeah and
they have different uses and so if we
were to look for that we go into the
neural network section so we see there's
general neural networks and then we see
RN ends and neural networks are part of
supervised and unsupervised right
exactly so you see how you know you
programmed it so that when you put your
cursor over it it would highlight where
it connects
- what yeah - what nodes yeah and then
you zoom in here like you were doing and
you see we're right yeah it looks like I
found an error but so an Ellis TM is
actually a type of RNN and so yeah so
there's CN N and there's RN n and those
do different things but they're both
subclasses of neural networks and so I
wanted a way to visualize the whole
space in there's a simple way yeah I
thought it's a graph so yeah let's make
a network visualization and that's
exactly what I did and so if you want so
let's say you come in and you're very
confused about the machine learning
space you've heard all these different
concepts during maybe enter names
Coursera course yeah and you know ok ok
how does this all fit together so you
just start at machine learning the the
center you can learn about like what it
is when they use it
how to use it the different tools
libraries that are available for it you
know the top ones and then some extra
links I even linked to end earnings
course here and it's and then you say ok
well I want to specifically go into
let's say supervised learning so you
click here and then you can learn about
that what it is and then see that oh
well from supervised learning we see
that there's neural networks you can do
naive Bayes or different types of
regressions SVM support vector machines
all these things and it gives you just a
more holistic view of the space and you
know kind of demystifies it which is
yeah a common theme which is what we
care a lot of us demystifying complex
things - more simplified ways of
understanding it but also with still
caring about all the different variables
that go into it this is really great
this AI concept map is just like it's
fantastic you know you go to clustering
it's like ok it's a part of
dimensionality reduction yep and then
and there's all these different types of
the clustering that happened you know
semi-supervised learning this is great
and you can you know you can click and
drag it's dynamic in the sense you know
fun to play with fun to play with when I
click send me supervised learning you
know you you
not for now but let me know ya soon
there will be you know eventually you'll
have you know these written up and I
mean it looks like this function so
interestingly well you know in a
three-dimensional right it looks like
it's and this was fairly simple to build
with d3 two really simple to build
there's a lot of boilerplate stuff you
need to add in and that's one the
reasons why I made phase sweet so then
let's go to face is there some shared
more than we should show here um no I
think that'll do it that's about it
let's pull up the jiff now Ronnie or the
static image or jiff the it differed be
go through the jiff and the jiff is
relating to the AI concept map or this
so this was it's relating to the
framework but the framework was inspired
by problems that I ran into when
developing the AI concept map yep
so this is kind of a bunch together
there's a lot of text and lines but this
is a network visualizing the actors and
the lamerz are Rob in the what lame is a
Rob
Oh a mr. Rob play oh this is the actor
that's crazy you just said that because
I just emailed my gfv see if she wanted
to go to phantom or low is right yeah
crazy it is just a little bit yeah
and so sorry and he'll there and now
you're showing how they're related
alright so this is a very famous data
set and so I use it a lot of my demos
I'm not really sure what the links
represent I think it's just like which
seems they are in together but it's
great for if you want to do any kind of
network analysis so in this case what we
see here is we're doing a breadth-first
search so we're searching through the
graph starting from count it will turn
purple first right there and also whole
load Torrell and from there it colors
them at different levels and it
okay so it expands until it hits the
whole graph you can see which characters
are furthest away so the ones that
eventually highlight orange are the ones
that are furthest away from bullet rail
and count yeah so this was very easy to
build
I think the demo ends up being only a
few lines and to me that's that's the
goal that's making it easy to do
something like this and building on top
of that you can take any kind of network
with any kind of structure with any kind
of simulation or visualization that you
want to do and do that simply so
building the infrastructure for complex
systems researchers to effectively do
their analyses yep yep and look at this
this is an analysis on on
actors/actresses in let mr. Rob versus
the economy is a whole different scale
different variables it's just it's so
interesting how these things defer and
let's let's go ahead and talk about some
of the other like bigger picture stuff
as well because I think that's so
fascinating and important to talk about
okay so we've been talking about complex
systems how to visualize them this is
important I don't think we've talked too
much about simulations mmm-hmm so when
you take a complex system like these
cause-and-effect structures within a
topic a hot-button topic let's say like
abortion or whatever and then you are
then trying to figure out maybe run a
simulation now how would you go about
doing that
ooh so trying to kind of visualize what
about abortion kids there's a lot of
different ways you could go about it
let's say you want to visualize all the
main like let's say the pull it apart
exhibition like who are the people in
Congress and local governments etc who
are involved and what are their leanings
and then like how do you
okay take advantage of that to run a
simulation and say like if you started a
movement in Anchorage Alaska right would
you be able to affect the the national
view majority view towards the abortion
issue so that's one thing you could do
just make a network model all the
politicians there their circles yeah or
you could model the population itself
this sounds so difficult it's extremely
difficult there it gave me a very
difficult problem tomorrow yeah but I
mean that's those are the ones that I
think are important to tackle as well
yeah yeah and you can open-source that
data set of terms of how the politicians
stand on this on this exactly abortion
and then other people can come in and
run other simulations on oh well what
happens if that if a different movement
starts in Birmingham or in Detroit it's
exactly and there are some data sets
that exist I mean there are websites
that keep track of every politicians
past vote or like what are their plague
leanings and who do they associate with
what communities are they on and so that
data might be available it's just it
might be the wrong format or you just
don't know how to find it or scrape it
maybe they have a really bad API to get
the data from and so it the I don't want
I want those to be the main problems
that people are solving hopefully those
will get solved by other frameworks that
buy made by people with better expertise
in those areas than I but I want the
visualization part of it once you have
that data set like what do you do with
it
I want the barriers in the way of making
those kinds of simulations gone and that
should enable the average programmer who
doesn't have expertise in d3 or whatever
library they choose to work with to just
do their meaningful analyses with the
data that they find elsewhere and use
that to inform people to enact change
themselves to build applications on top
of that so maybe
economy they do an analysis and they
realize wow this is a very like
underserved sector because there doesn't
exist a company that does X like
autonomous vehicles need I don't know
like pound of its headlights I don't
even know what that means but maybe you
solve that problem yes yes that was good
thank you
start a timer fifteen minutes there's a
couple couple thoughts their first
thought is that it is it's it's
interesting to take something else maybe
like how a commodity moves in the
economy something like toothpaste
how does toothpaste move in the economy
and what areas by the most toothpaste
you know why do they buy the most
toothpaste how soon will will Africa
want Amazon to start be shipping
toothpaste to Africa exactly will
Alibaba come in and ship more toothpaste
to Africa who knows and so how to model
these things out well this crest have
the market share this Colgate have the
market share are they are those both
Procter & Gamble companies I don't even
know no idea I don't even know but P&G
Wendy's everywhere yeah I know brands
and then so the maybe another idea is to
to well just as you you know mark it out
the way that underwear is shipped and
moved across the planet or even
something like iPhones and you know cell
phones so all these different sort of
commodities can also be simulated in
different ways it would be like if you
basically took that bubble on the AI
network that you made there the concept
network and you clicked and dragged it
over to it maybe a different area and
you said that let's say that the
manufacturing facility moves to a
cheaper labor area now how much this
would be simulation for maybe Procter &
Gamble is how much more money would you
make for the shareholders how much
faster would you produce the the
toothpaste exactly all these different
variables right and you know economies
are I wouldn't say they're easy to
simulate but they're easier to simulate
them people so like doing idea of
psychometrics are hard but hard and
subjective and all the data is very
skewed and stuff like that and so with
the economy you have
dollars you have a very defined metric
that you can use say like okay if we
move our factory over to where was it
somewhere let's say move into central
California in central California then
you know will your customers or will
your logistics companies be able to get
out there with their shipping supplies
and [ __ ] all over do you have the right
infrastructure in place do you have to
buy a warehouse what are all these
decisions you have a dollar value
attached to it and so you could run a
simulation on how many people do you
think would buy it I you know if that
doesn't change customer behavior then
all you have to do is simulate the the
worst case and the best case take the
average and try to see what is the
actual value of that action yeah and to
be able to map out the value of
different simulations is a fascinating
ability and I'm really happy that you
know that you're studying data you're
studying visualization or studying
simulations can you teach us about chaos
theory quick chaos theory is that like
the butterfly effect yes so chaos theory
kind of is the basis of the butterfly
effect and I'm no chaos theory expert
but essentially what the the theoretics
behind it is chaos theory you have some
kind of system and if you make a small
change to that system and it's early
phases so for example if you you have
the u.s. you think out the presidents
like the smile thing right on the street
you smile the next person will be like
potentially smile I could butterfly
effect right so yeah change is an
initial changes an initial structure
initial changes in the structure of a
system will have unpredictable / large
consequences in the end state of the
system take out so if you take the
social network of the u.s. take out the
president just one one person right
that one affected all that much
massively different massively different
yeah that's an example but what if we
took you out of the system or maybe
right it wouldn't I don't have an effect
maybe we would have less of an effect
yeah yeah yeah and so it's still having
a freaking you're taking some initial
condition you would have an emotional
response from like your mom and your dad
your family and they need to have an
emotional response from your friends so
that would cause yeah exactly they're
friends yeah and so maybe that slight
slight slight emotional change and my
friend could lead them on an entirely
different life time yeah remember the
emotional response you had a two line
restaurant that was the most I've ever
seen you yet it's funny because it's
gonna even get even more even less sort
of aggressive and agitated as we go to
our I go to our my fourth meditation
straight around those hairs first in the
fall we'll be going to that it'll be a
lot of fun we've covered so much stuff I
think this is interesting you're talking
about this on the way out we can talk
about this the way that a simulation can
be used for psychometrics as well there
seem to be you know the the benefits are
things like oh I have no friends in this
area I just moved here and it's like
[ __ ] yeah we have tons of people that we
can get you as friends because you know
we know your interest we know their
interests we know they're also looking
for friends boom there you go now you
have tons of more friends and so stuff
like that that makes me feel very
optimistic and happy and then there's
the you know analyzing people
psychometric profiles and then feeding
them hate ads which i think is
disgusting and I think really needs to
just get this completely distinguished
and distinguish the sexes England
extinguished there we go it out
extinguished little opposite society
yeah exactly
so so there's that there's we give all
these great examples about the economy
you actually were teaching me about how
and I thought this was really
interesting because I have also been
kind of talking about this but not from
this perspective that you taught me
about it which was that
maybe the reason why the economy
functions the way it does is because of
the relationships that people have with
each other as in you and I are starting
to get closer now it's much more likely
that you and I might go and you know
spend money between each other spend
money with each other that kind of a
thing and that's like when you have your
mom or your dad your mom or your dad are
much more likely they from 0 0 to 18
they basically pay for everything for
you yeah as someone that's being birthed
into the world and growing into the
world so just this idea that you know
the parent is gonna be responsible for
paying for everything for you but for
example someone on the street has no
interest whatsoever in paying anything
on your behalf in almost every single
case right so just this general idea of
this nuclear family and the way that the
nuclear family functions in an economy
and the way that things like you know
that's kind of like more nationalistic
in the sense and then the global istic
sense and if you were to maybe like get
dosed up with LSD or if you were to
maybe go through tons of meditation
practice and just eradicate your ego and
understand the whole we are one
mentality and stuff that actually and
interestingly enough was and some
experiments of the MKULTRA which it's
just crazy to think about this but if
you break the nuclear bonds of that
structure it changes the way that the
people in you interact with then the
family and also from outside of the
family in it changes it maybe increases
the idea of a family to the planet and
then that changes the way that economies
markets working borders work nationalism
globalism works yeah it's a difficult
thing to explain yeah I mean so a few
thoughts on that then so yes the economy
is an emergent property of some system
some social system and so that means the
economy of the US is vastly different
from the economy of China and that's
because we have large structural
differences in those systems the way
people interact China is a very strong
family culture in the US that's sort of
starting to disappear and so governments
being organized organisms that want to
survive constantly competing against
each other and internally to make sure
everything's functioning properly they
so well backtracking a little bit if you
change the fundamental structure of the
system too fast for that government to
adapt so let's say the family ties in
the u.s. just like completely disappear
in five years whether by some just like
radical cultural shift or something else
then the economy would change or the
needs of the economy would change maybe
too too fast for the government to keep
up and the government would essentially
not be able to function and adapt and it
would cause a lot of tension possibly a
collapse and so governments are very
aware of this and so they like to keep
things in in an innovative stasis where
there is progress being made but at a
pace that the government can keep up
with and that's why I have such as a
large hatred for bureaucracy here ah
Christine I was gonna say this is
something I acknowledged a long time ago
all bureaucracy does is just gives the
chance for those that are in power to
figure something out to really stay in
control hey while we're at it I just
wanted to shout out to Fernandez Ramirez
who's watching he always watches and he
grunts he thinks the graphics are cool I
just wanted to do that thank you thank
you so much for sharing for watching
thank you Ron good shout out yeah
bureaucracy holds us back
innovation dirty rat bastard but I think
a lot of people get it wrong and wide
bureaucracy holds us back and I think
it's this also keeps us safe in some
ways yes in some ways right you know
that adaptation you can't have like the
cultures are very hard to change and so
if the cultures of a society change very
quickly you're gonna have people left
behind and that causes polarization
tension between classes stuff like that
and so again going back to this idea
of being able to envision a system as
complex and thinking about societies
about emergent properties of the world
like the economy or like transportation
transportation lines the way that
industry works just think about all
these things as a complex system and
taking lots of ideas from that field is
I think extremely fundamentally valuable
yep
in order to understand the world and
current state with policy economics how
your social network works stuff like
that yep and you're right there in the
nuance in the gray area you're right
there
making sure that people wanted to
calculate all of the variables
understand that an effect doesn't have
one cause it has tons of different
causes yeah so I'm really happy to call
you my friend and I'm very happy to be
able to continue picking your brain over
time and learning from you definitely
amplifying it we got a lot to mesh and a
lot to work on together I'm really
excited for that
let's ask you a couple questions on the
way out first questions do you think
we're alone in the cosmos no I think I
think that would be silly to say that we
were I mean life evolves very quickly I
think I learned that from Jill who we
had a nice lunch with a couple that last
weekend and the math would be
statistically surprising I think if we
were to end up alone and I guess it
depends on your definition of life
intelligent life or just like bacteria
floating around
I think there's definitely bacteria
floating around somewhere intelligent
life yes but with stipulations you know
it's hard to tell and then do you think
that we're in a simulation
I like to not think anything I like I
don't like yes or no answers will impact
the nuance of your answer yeah so I
don't know and is it relevant really I
think I think that is the core issue of
my problem with that question is what
does it change if we're in a simulation
does it mean that we're deterministic
would we be deterministic anyway if we
were not and to me life seems inherently
meaningless so while I'm here I'm gonna
do my best to make life as meaningful or
as happy for as many people as possible
and I don't think that whether I'm in a
simulation will affect that I I think
that that goal is kind of tangential to
whether or not we are from a thought
standpoint yeah I think it's I think
it's a real possibility
I think I'd lean more to yes it's we
have no way of knowing how long
existence even beyond our universe has
been going on and I think that
simulations based on my work are very
useful and so maybe there is some super
intelligent race that's been simulating
us I don't know how I would feel about
that I probably haven't come to terms of
that yeah fuck'em Hey what's uh what's
the most confusing thing about reality
being that you feel that life is
meaningless what's the most confusing
thing about our collective reality that
you have these humans are beautiful man
it's just so confusing and so complex
right it's I've said that word too many
times I think in this hour but humans
are full of nuance and I could spend my
whole life studying them many people do
and I will never figure them out they
were all so full of [ __ ] you got it it's
a new question that we've added to the
show what's the most confusing thing
about reality
so that's a good answer then there's so
much me wants unpack all because I enter
a lot what you might get that answer I
will yes exactly good I hope we get that
answer a lot ok the last question what
do you think the most beautiful thing in
the world well hmm that's a hard one
that's a very hard one I think
I like sand a lot sand is neutral it's
just there
I think looking at a desert I wonder if
I skewed his answer with my no I've
always liked desert you you are deserts
interesting lot I thought you were gonna
go to beach first that's interesting you
went to desert
yeah well the side deserts fascinating
as well they're just human I mean lots
of conversations to have about how
living in a desert affects your frame of
mind ah correct yeah because that's like
the meditation retreat that I was just
talking about as well there's when you
are away from social connections when
you're away from the internet where
you're away from all the noise what
happens to your mind yep
typically we go and revisit memories we
find new ways of maybe finding water and
food and it's waste of different
societies form in different environments
versus desert very different yep
interesting can you just give me give me
another 20 seconds on sand why sand is
so it's neutral it's just there tend
like us right there's so much sand lots
of humans we are just like moving around
in the wind it doesn't really matter in
the grand scheme of things where the
sand ends up it's still gonna be on
earth and although we may not be on
earth forever we're still in the
universe we're still in some container
and largely we're part of nature and
that's really what it comes down to for
me we're just sand laying in the Sun
soaking up heat enjoying our time yep I
love that that's a very meditative sort
of understanding of of life and being
happy okay this has been fascinating
Matt think he's absolutely coming onto
our show thank you for having me yeah
I mean there's so much to unpack
everyone I really appreciate you guys
tuning in there's so much to still learn
about data visualization data science
making it as relatable as possible
learning cool things like d3 to be able
to add this into our into our daily
lives understanding all the nuance and
all
the multi variability of the way that
things are affected by all these
different causes so that it's not just
so binary or ABCD it's not just that
easy and let's get more people talking
about this go and share this with more
people comment below with your thoughts
subscribe during the family go and
create with this content or just consume
it go make things go write a blog go
make a program go and make a video about
this as well join us on patreon help
support us help us scale this content
impact more people would greatly
appreciate it thanks for on our producer
and director much love everyone talk
soon
peace
[Music]
you